after a critically acclaimed and wildly
successful origin story Wonder Woman is
heading to 1984 and when she gets there
to find a new foe lying in wait
Wonder Woman director patty Jenkins has
shared the first official image of
actress Kristen Wiig in character on set
of Wonder Woman 1984 portraying the
character Barbara and Minerva aka the
villainous cheetah while it appears to
be a look at Minerva in a normal 80's
lady form it's still cool to see the
character come to life
for the first time ever in a live-action
film even if it does just like a
postcard from a Natural History Museum
with Wiig standing in a dark room
surrounded by exhibits dabbling in a
big-screen super villainy is a new
career move for Wiig who made a name for
herself in comedy with Saturday Night
Live and a Golden Globe nominated turn
in bridesmaids she starred in the reboot
of the Ghostbusters franchise in 2016
but this is a first big foray into the
superhero genre Cheetahs cinematic
backstory is still unclear and in the
comics it varies quite a bit in her
first incarnation as Barbara and Minerva
she's an ambitious archaeologist from a
wealthy family with a flexible moral
compass she gains supernatural powers
while seeking immortality from an
ancient god of plants or by cutting
herself on an ancient dagger or she's
cursed depending on which series you
read in all of our incarnations the
transformation leaves her in a tortured
existence somewhere between human and
feline her natural ambitions are
supercharged by her immense new strength
betweenness inspired casting and the
expected but still unexplained return of
Steve Trevor
Wonder Woman 1984 shaping up to be among
the most interesting movies coming out
of Warner Brothers in DC in the near
future jenkins confirmed on Twitter
earlier this month that despite
sacrificing himself for the safety of
the entire world
Chris Pines Trevor will be in The Wonder
Woman sequel welcome to Wonder Woman
1984 Steve Trevor Jenkins tweeted along
with a photo of pine looking totally 80s
in era appropriate clothes including
what appears to be a Members Only jacket
you remember that Trevor appeared to
have died at the end of the first Wonder
Woman flick which was set in 1917 during
World War one but it looks like he
somehow went on to live for another 67
years and didn't age a single day is
this Steve Trevor a relative of the
original Steve Trevor is there some sort
of time travel in play as he
to stylish hallucination we'll have to
wait and find out as a bonus treat
Wonder Woman herself actress gal gadot
also took to Twitter recently to share a
photo from the sequel in it diana has
seen staring at a wall of screens most
of which display period-appropriate
shapes colors and stock images but one
shows actor Larry Hagman as jr. Ewing on
the 1980s primetime soap opera Dallas
from the original film's performance we
already know the team behind this can
make an excellent superhero flick Wonder
Woman broke a ton of Records in the
summer of 2017 becoming the
highest-grossing DC extended universe
film ever at the domestic box office the
most commercially successful superhero
origin story movie in history and the
top earning live-action film directed by
a woman in sotol the flick took home 821
million dollars worldwide and sits
certified fresh' with a 92 percent
critical score and an 88% audience
rating on Rotten Tomatoes speaking with
Entertainment Tonight Jenkins promised
that the sequel will be a completely
fresh experience compared to its
predecessor it's not Wonder Woman to to
us is an entirely new adventure when the
woman 1984 will be out in theaters on
November 1st 2019 thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we do love to
[Music]